dans la nuit de samedi à dimanche
bernard tapie et sa femme dominique ont
été violemment agressés dans leur
résidence secondaire séquestré roué de
coups par leurs agresseurs le couple a
finalement réussi à prévenir les secours
suite à cette terrible agression les
premiers éléments de l'enquète ont
permis de dresser un portrait des
agresseurs présumés importe à qui a été
l'occasion pour jean lucien
personnalités affidés au rassemblement
national de réaliser une petite sortie
comme il les aime tant sur les
agresseurs de mera tapis sont quatre
dont trois africains et un de type
nord-africain une déclaration à laquelle
stéphane tapis répondait hier soir sur
notre plateau qui se souviennent d'eux
qui a sauvé les gens dans l'hyper cacher
c'était un immigré pourtant jambe ici a
poursuivi sur twitter en déclarant
pourquoi taire obstinément que les
agresseurs de ses parents sont aussi
d'origine immigrés pourquoi parler
d'immigrés est obligatoire dans un cas
est interdit dans l'autre les
déclarations qui une fois encore ont été
jugés racistes et stigmatisantes par de
nombreux internautes
alors toute polémique sur bernard tapie
gens mais cela est il allé trop loin et
jean vayssettes avec le choix remercie
d'être là j'ai le droit de répondre mais
cherche juste avant qu'on débatte là
dessus qu'ils se vous avez pensé du
témoignage qu on avait juste un moyen
énormément de gens qui réagissent 1 sur
exactement sur le ce qui arrive au
peuple ouïghours en chine
qu'est-ce que vous avez regardé le
témoignage oui j'ai regardé j'ai été
très ému ça m'a beaucoup touché et je
crois que nul ne devrait être renfermé
ou poursuivi pour ses croyances
religieuses
son affiliation politique ou ses
origines et je crois que ce que j'ai vu
là rappelle un autre âge et un âge
particulièrement sombre et j'espère que
justice sera faite et que ces malheureux
qui sont effectivement comment dirais-je
persécutés pour leur religion et bien
puisse un jour recouvrer la liberté et
que le monde entier sache ce qui se
passe là bas c'est c'est incroyable a on
va essayer ou les liens à notre petite
échelle d'essayer de faire quelque chose
avec le avec le gouvernement d'alerter
le gouvernement mais c'est vrai qu'il
faut vraiment que tous les gouvernements
soient alertés et que c'était bien
d'avoir un responsable de vos offres
mais ça aurait été bien d'avoir un
responsable on va essayer dans la ligue
populaire de chine
en face de ce témoignage afin qu'ils
puissent être expliquées exhaler débats
contradictoires sont présents mais on va
lancer d'ailleurs pour demain quelqu'un
qui viendra s'exprimer et
voilà parce que c'est important voilà
est aussi quelqu'un du gouvernement pour
sa essayer de remontrer ce témoignage
pour qu'ils puissent bouger et faire
bouger les autres pays au plus vite à
leurs tweets polémique sur bernard tapie
est ce que jean messia est allé trop
loin
vous allez à vous répondre dans un
instant gens pour vous il a été trop
loin pour vous lire il a été trop loin
moi je suis pas spécialement d'accord
avec les idées de jean bessière après je
mets à sa place il essayait de rebondir
sur n'importe quel fait d'actualité pour
faire entendre vos idées ce que je peux
comprendre la revanche je pense que le
fait d'actualité il était mal choisie
parce que l'agression de bernard tapie a
rien à dire à part que c'est abject et
que ces terribles s'attaquer à quelqu'un
qui souffre et qui s'attaque à quelqu'un
mais déjà tout court mais qu'après qui
luttent contre la maladie c'est encore
pire c'est terrible donc je trouve que
le fait d'actualité n'était pas très
bien choisis et j'ai l'impression que ça
vous a mis un peu mal à l'aise puisque
pendant l'émission vous avez écrit à
cyril est ce que vous allez regretter
déjà au moment où vous les avez posté
non parce que dans mon tout et tout le
monde a oublié que gm souhaitait amour
établi voilà ça c'est la première chose
mais voilà la deuxième chose c'est que
j'ai eu l'occasion d'exprimer à laurent
tapie que j'ai croisés sur le plateau de
ses news
effectivement toute ma compassion
vis-à-vis de ce qu'elle avait subi ses
parents donc je suis pas un monstre mais
je fais la distinction entre l'être
humain nul être humain n'a ne doit subir
que ça est la personnalité politique
qu'a été bernard tapie puisqu'elle a été
un ministre socialiste et à ce titre
effectivement on peut interroger la
politique maintenant si vous voulez moi
j'ai quand j'ai révélé l'identité des
agresseurs
je les fais commencé d'ailleurs valeurs
actuelles qui l'a révélé d'accord valeur
à l'actuel était au courant comment
parce que les flics l'ont révélé et
pourquoi et comment les flics l'ont
révélé ils l'ont révélée parce que
c'était les époux tapie eux mêmes qui
ont décrit les agresseurs est normal
pourquoi pourquoi je le dis c'est la
dernière partie de l'émission souple
pourquoi j'ai dit ça parce que c'est
merci allez-y jean-louis non pour
pourquoi j'ai dit ça effectivement dans
plein d'affaires les origines ethniques
et la couleur de peau est au centre d
indignation quand c'était michel est
clair tout le monde a à souligner sa
couleur de peau on s'est essayé à des
bougnats même ce qu'on s'était george
clooney dans des délires
il ya un drame un fait divers terrible
un homme et une femme agressée vous
n'avez aucune compassion vous n'avez
l'état du coeur c'est vous tombez dans
votre récupération politique solide mais
comment vous n'êtes en effet mathieu
verdin
mais monsieur verdez lorsque
l'immigration eto'o est au coeur d'un
acte héroïque on parle plis médiatement
dan immigrés maliens
quand il ya eu les on a parlé de la
nativité
lassana batelli dondon dont me dont le
dont stéphane tapie a parlé hier
lorsqu'il a commis son acte héroïque qui
par ailleurs a contesté tout le monde
arrête condamné cette année c'est anne
émigrés maliens c'est anne immigrés
c'est un c'est un malien d'origine
on a stigmatisé ou là on a focalisé sur
sa couleur de peau alors je vois pas
pourquoi lorsque l'immigration soit elle
et victimaire soit elle est héroïque on
peut en parler immédiatement il ya
toujours aucune décence et aucune
récupération et aucune
instrumentalisation et dès qu'il s'agit
d'une immigration tortionnaires
délinquante ou violente
il faut la terre et la mer mais non mais
jean sala on n'a rien à voir c'est dans
un contexte on a on a quelqu'un qui
s'est fait agresser et lui faut pourquoi
pourquoi vous parlez vous aimez pour
commenter la nomine comeca première
chose d'abord ce premier tweet à verser
vont penser
oui mon chat bernard tapie sa femme
c'est tout c'est grâce à oui monsieur
alyzia vous est pour moi un agitateur me
d'être si vous êtes une sorte de zemmour
low cost moi je me trompe et pourquoi le
colosse est désobligeant ce que vous
dites low cost nos soldats n'ont cessé
ses tresses et très désobligeant goodies
et madame et c'est très insultant
non c'est vrai que ça soit issu le temps
ce que vous dites moi c'est insultant
chassaing surtout des mon papa oui si
l'on est votre c'est peut-être votre ami
avec les autres qui venaient la voiture
d'avis - oui mais on n'est pas là pour
insulter pour moi la voilà aussi parce
que son idéologie est complètement bien
sûr avec celle de zemmour oui bah oui
mais voilà point celui des légendes
histoires la piste qui est sûr c'est que
vous vous êtes pas alcoolique mais bon
ça c'est au tour de machine à cause du
tout voilà oui pédégistes moi ce que je
ne comprends pas dans votre tweet
monsieur c'est qu'en fait vous dit en
gros ils sont noirs et ils sont arabes
donc en gros c'est pour ça qu'ils
agressent non êtes-vous racialisée le si
c'est vrai c'est moins pire racialise
bah si c'est vous qui attendez attendez
on racialise à longueur de temps
qui sait qui parle de racisées québec
qui sait qui parle de privilèges blanc
trône de la tourelle vous arrêtez pas
dire il sait attendait unique sweeting
red hot pursuit ou et pour ce tweet je
me suis fait rentrer dans le lard
insulté injurié c'est normal
les agresseurs eux mêmes n'ont pas été
un multi vraie crapule les vrais vraie
nature
les vrais rafle sûrs et les vraie
crapule et les vraies salles aubry
dénonce empire osé s'attaquer un vieil à
un vieil homme malade lui et sa femme
d'accord et le fait de ne pas les
traiter comme tel simplement parce
qu'ils viennent de certaines
immigrations c'est ça qui est raciste
pas le prouver et cinq militants
identitaires on aurait immédiatement les
fascistes déco la victoire était chez
colaert cimétière vous que vous savez
quoi je suis très naïf et très con je
pensais vous n'avez vous excuser non
parce que quand un homme de son âge qui
lutte contre un cancer je suis tout à
fait favorable qui se fait traîner
parler bien sûr des ces absences dix ans
et que vous écrivez votre tweet
totalement inapproprié et inhumain
commettez je pensais je pensais
sincèrement ce que le bon rétablissement
c'est de la provocation à la fin après
tout ce que vous dites mais vous allez
oublier tous les problèmes nam et à ta
race ou de couleur en théorie xavier
juste et que vous alliez juste un moment
donné revenir sur vos propos je suis
désolé c'est honteux mais attendez mais
que quand quand quand ben hammam
dunga ça ça n'a rien à voir rien à voir
qui a sauvé un enfant du balcon tsan en
a immédiatement racialisée on a dit
l'immigration ou l'arrêter oui tout
parce que les origines
je regrette de pas voir millions bon
rétablissement au début aux voix la main
sur le fond j'ai raison il est temps si
vous voulez que certaines personnes
comprennent ceux qui ont passé comprenez
vous comprenez que la famille kabyle et
plus et pu être blessés par vos tweets
surtout hâte à titre humain sans doute
mais à titre politique c'est juste la
vérité
ça fait 40 ans mais que nous avons des
élites politiques qui nous explique mes
inventions voulait pas sortir et laisser
sa mascotte au fait oui tu comme ça mais
justement on parle pas une amitié exact
faut sortir de vous le dire j'ai exprimé
j'ai exprimé effectivement toute ma
compassion et toute ma sympathie à la
famille tapie je dire personne ne peut
accepter de tels agissements mais me
voir insulter alors même que les
agresseurs n'a aucun américain les gens
comment il faut sortir les la politique
comme ça twitte aujourd'hui tel est le
cas c'est ce qui se passe qui se bat oui
au fin 2007 qui n'essaie pas de faire
des récup macho c'est la récupération
bernard tapie a été un ministre
socialiste il a à ce moment là après
l'agression s'en tape
il était sale et problème si vous voulez
c'est qu'il a participé à un réseau qui
aujourd'hui pète à la figure des bobos
et départ grecia mac
la seule vérité votre tout c'est quoi
c'est que vous avez une faute peut se
récupérer 1 et menin sur un événement
vous avez montré du doigt ces
communautés dont le seul but une fois
plus qu'un art ou foutez de moi trop
d'africains est un type m'a north africa
sérénité sa mode accord occulte la
mairie le but de tout c'est quoi c'est
de montrer du doigt une fois du succès
si si si si c'est de dire vous avez vu
ce sont ces gens là qui vous agressent
caribou
il faut bout de souffle et vous êtes que
vous me souffler que sont les braises
racine avait toujours dit toujours ne
vous ai pas vus avoir la moindre
pincettes lorsqu'il s'essaye ta cg dire
que toute la police était raciste que
les blancs sont racistes que les
français j'ai dit on a dépassé par ces
populations plan ce cap mois l'agent ce
que vous n'avez pas compris en fait on
est sur deux débats différentes nous ce
qu'on vous demande et au niveau de ce
tweet c'est un petit peu d'humanité et
de prévention aux 100 compressions
sérénité de la politique ou de savoir
s'il était muni socialiste gilles s'il
avait fait il avait été président on
s'en fout de sa ville je verrai je vais
répondre à ça je dis que ce qui est
arrivé
le drame qui est arrivé au couple tapie
touche des milliers de français depuis
des années des années s'est évanoui eu
la moindre compassion pour ces français
qui subissent ça de la part de ses
passes d'immigration ça recommence pas à
comment effectivement une certaine
immigration sont sur-représentés dans la
délinquance la violence
vous savez qui j'ai pensé moi en premier
à mes parts on imaginer que ça arrive à
vous passer ça ben moi mes parents n'ont
jamais favorisé l'immigration massive
mais il m'a dit on les appelle ça fait
40 ans qu'on dit que l'immigration est
une richesse pour la france il faut bien
que les normes est pourri sociale mais
qui ont concouru les sujets isabelle
bernier a misé avec la non le problème
jamais que vous nous dites que vous avez
une la compassion le problème c'est que
dans vos tweak est beaucoup trop rapide
parce qu'il est y ait une récupération
très nette est immédiate
le problème c'est que cette compassion
gens elle ne se sent absolument pas y a
pas un mot pour eux et effectivement
quand vous mettez bon rétablissement à
la fin on a l'impression que c'est plus
une expression déroulage de gueule vous
savez moi je sais pas alors on vous
pouvez me reprocher beaucoup de choses
sauf d'être fou c'est à dire que je dis
toujours ce que je pense et je pense
toujours ce que je dis d'accord non
quand le s'associant temps quand je dis
bon rétablissement s'est vraiment que je
le pense alors par contre j'aurais dû
d'abord mettre le bon rétablissement
avant contexte du twin pas mais sur le
fond il faut bien que les personnes de
manière générale qui ont participé à
sept ans sauvagement de la france
comment vous qu'elle soit enrichi aussi
il y avait assez de richesse pour la
france après c'est toujours pareil avec
françois pignon bernard bernard françois
pignon c'est toujours pareil il faut
l'avouer le mahb large à ce que ça vous
va bien vous avez une cure en tout cas
vous avez une culture un petit peu
encore un petit peu étriqué nasa vous
combien cher alain bollery alors il est
il a aucune humanité ce monsieur il est
tout le temps dans la récupération
politique et je regrette qu'au passé
autant de temps sur les plateaux à
déverser votre assurance allez tu vas tu
vas dire tout le temps la même chose
aussi à donne ton avis sur le twittos
linguère tout pacte des loups d'absents
twitté sont bons c'est de l'ironie non
mais donne ton avis c'est pas la peine
de dire si dans le même temps même chose
aussi ses primes
à oui oui satine personnellement je
trouve que relier une agression
supergrave du cou qui est celle de
bernard tapie et de sa femme
je trouve ça vraiment mais horrible
rinié soit au type des agresseurs mais
ça tu n'as aucun rapport c'est bien
c'est ce que super mahdavi les traits on
dirait presque vous jubilez que c'est
monsieur disait ceci met des millions de
français devraient même vous les
journées de sa vraie la paix l'amour et
la presse quotidienne régionale et voyez
comment la l'immigration est impliqué
dans la magie du pays bon sens alors
évidemment j'aurais explose à la figure
aujourd'hui ça et ça vous fait trépigner
mais c'est pourtant la réalité
jean-michel qu'on a pensé c'est
carrément le tweet il aurait plus le
régime en zone 4c croyez pas bastien
prochain tiger ça te servira de leçon la
formation c'est vraiment ironique c'est
sarcastique
ça n'a aucun sens à la famille faisait
une exégèse débile de mon tweet acheter
quelque chose bizarrement tout va on a
compris comme son père jean missia parce
que malgré sa honte on vous tombe dessus
et dieu sait que je condamne toutes vos
pensées
mais il faut pas il ya eu un sondage
aujourd'hui 18 à 32 18 ans à 35 ans la
majorité des gens on vote pour le
rassemblement national aujourd'hui voilà
donc c'est une réalité
donc c'est pas un vol un vote constate
contestataires c'est un vote vraiment
d'adhésion au pensez à vos pensées à
votre courant de pensée mais pour autant
je trouve que vous comment dire on a
l'impression que vous voulez monter les
gens les uns contre les autres du tout
si ce qui montre les gens les uns contre
les autres madame ce sont ceux qui à
longueur de journée traite les français
de back to de salses et francs et cetera
je vous voyais de l'année
partout sauf là où il faut la voir voilà
ma progression
c'est ça moi qui agressait les jambes un
jour mes chats les élèves j'en sors mais
vous stigmatisez geoplin on va pas on
n'est pas dans le temps vous savez sur
monsieur andré bercoff ce matin sur sud
radio
oui il ira qui rapporte oui ce que les
agresseurs ont dit à tapis cantat qui
leur a dit j'ai toujours été avec les
migrants j'ai toujours été pour
l'ouverture des frontières le gars lui a
répondu vas te faire [ __ ] ce temps
est mort voilà la réalité voilà la
véritable elle qu'il faut en informer
ses agents mais chan on parle de deux de
bernard tapie
est ce que vous avez fait ça pour faire
le buzz non mais ça du tout à l'arrivée
ça est-ce que vous soyez prêt est ce qu
est ce que vous avez envie de présenter
des excuses mine de rien à la famille
tapie ou pas du tout je ne vais pas
présenté des excuses mais je vais lui
apporter tout mon soutien dans cette
épreuve parce que c'en est une
et effectivement je rejoins ce que tout
ce qui était dit tout à l'heure je
l'avoué je n'aimerais pas que ça arrive
à mes parents mais j'estime que
politiquement ce genre de chose doit
ouvrir les yeux d'une certaine élite
politique qui effectivement a imposé aux
fins très regretté non je ne regrette
pas à des jeux les soutient dans cette
année la part de votre tweet moi je ne
regrette pas j'espère que du coup
bernard tapie regrette lui sa politique
à l'écran du débat j'ai eu plaisir à ce
que disent les territoires oui à 58 pour
soe win on a car elle 2% et non pas il a
beaucoup de familles à vivre garde